a young man rammed
his car into two u.s capitol police
officers
before getting out of his vehicle with a
knife
police shot and killed this man
immediately
the usual suspects on the left were
saying this is another insurrection
this is right-wing terrorism this is the
trump issue we've got to have a national
conversation and then it turned out
he's a young black guy who's a follower
of louis farrakhan's nation of islam and
then the story went away
that was it story just went away
actually all ilhan omar could say was
that
this uh this killing would have been
worse if he had an ar-15
we actually have some evidence that the
ar-15 wouldn't have
as a national issue wouldn't have been a
big deal we'll get into that in just a
second
this narrative it goes it's not even
just in what people say and what people
are taught
it's in the stories that are chosen to
be emphasized it's the
conversation that goes on it's the 25
million dollar department at just one
school of diversity equity and inclusion
it's this institutional power it gets
back to that comment that my favorite
comment from
last week that was brought up at the top
of the show it seems like a force field
around democrats
it is it is it's a very well-funded very
effective force field
and we are all the marx okay we are all
the people who are
who are being influenced by it socially
engineered by it
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you